this is world stories and i'm sumisomos
ganda with your international reporters
magazine this week we moved to the beat
of the tsam dance in mongolia we take
off with bulgaria's new airport control
tower and hope you're hungry for some
creepy crawly creatures all that and
more coming up but first the united
nations says fighting energy poverty is
a key challenge for the world community
there are more than one billion people
who don't have reliable access to
electricity in developing countries
where poor infrastructure and limited
funds make it hard to provide power
renewable energies are an increasingly
effective solution we've seen how the
power of the sun and the wind can help
lift communities out of poverty but
don't forget the energy surging below
our feet geothermal energy that is in
kenya's great rift valley the heat and
steam coming from the earth could
provide electricity to millions untv's
lewis patron reports
kenya
a nation in the midst of rapid
transformation
with a growing population of more than
40 million people it's one of the
fastest developing economies in africa
but 75 of kenyans do not have regular
access to electricity
to meet their pressing energy needs some
people here may have found a solution in
the great rift valley
this volcanic rift was formed by the
slow splitting of the african continent
heat from the earth's core escapes
through the opening creating hot springs
and steam fields
now we're in olkaria and this is where
we have the geothermal power plants
the
biggest plant in africa
geophysicists like ana wairimu mwangi
keep track of the hot water and steam
deep under the ground
i learned all korea we use several
geophysical methods
to try and find places where we can
locate the wells for drilling for steam
to be connected to the power plants
there are three geothermal plants in
ulcaria highly pressurized steam comes
out of 20 wells and is directed through
a system of pipes toward the turbines
the system generates about 200 megawatts
or 17 of electricity produced in kenya
and that's just a fraction of the
estimated 10 000 megawatts of kenya's
untapped geothermal energy potential
which fully utilized could power
millions more homes
but the great rift valley is also home
to the hellsgate national park
some worry about the free movement of
animals being disturbed by the network
of pipes and roads from the nearby
plants and drilling requires the use of
large quantities of water sometimes
taken from protected wetlands
to minimize the environmental impact the
company has restored and reforested the
area surrounding geothermal wells after
drilling
the power plants re-inject the
by-product geothermal water into the
ground
drilling engineer siche
the best way is to inject it back into
the
reservoir that can be heated back and we
can possibly use it back after a certain
period of time to tap into the full
potential of geothermal energy as a
clean power source kenya has been
working with international experts in
the geothermal training program at
united nations university also known as
umu
half a world away at its base in iceland
the unu program has trained over 500
scientists and engineers from numerous
developing countries including 62
kenyans in the past 30 years
ludwig jerichson from the unu training
program
if you want to have a serious
development
you cannot only do it through
consultants you have to know yourself
what you're doing
anna is one of them
back home she's working with ken gen the
largest electricity producing company in
kenya on geothermal energy development
in the great african rift valley
the goal is to increase its production
by 25 times accounting for about 30
percent of the country's targeted energy
mix in 2013.
we're increasing capacity the industry
is becoming bigger we have many fields
that we are exploring
now it is now upon us the kenyans to
train other people
a promising project for the future
thanks to louis patron from untv for
that report
now to a traditional tibetan dance that
has spread its roots across asia the
tsam is a buddhist custom performed in
countries like china india bhutan and
mongolia
there the dance has long been part of
buddhist culture but the communist
regime that ruled the country for nearly
seven decades banned the psalm and other
religious ceremonies so performances
were few and far between nowadays the
tradition's been revived tmtv's george
sangenyav shows us the steps
the mongolian sam dance is a type of
religious mystery play that has its
origins in buddhist ceremonies
its name comes from the tibetan word
cham which means dance
some was originally performed by monks
to pacify angry gods
a performance of this size hasn't
happened for the last 20 years
the dance was outlawed for decades under
communist rule
i'm very happy that this mongolian chum
dance is being performed again in its
entirety
the thumb dance is both a type of active
meditation and a prayer
you could also describe the dance as an
act of shamanic exorcism a buddhist
blessing and a re-energizing experience
the tibetan dance was adopted in
mongolia in the mid 18th century and
performed on particular festivals and
holidays
soon each buddhist monastery developed
its own variation of the dance
tam dance took on its own mongolian
flavor reflecting local traditions and
ways of life
more than 500 monasteries had
established their own sam rituals by
1921
then came the mongolian revolution and
the start of soviet rule
in 1988 the dance was recognized as a
part of mongolian cultural heritage
people began to stage small sam rituals
in 1990 mainly for tourists the dancers
wear exquisite costumes the pointed
boots resemble the mouths of crocodiles
the masks represent deities
both costumes and masks are made from
gold silver copper leather silk satin
and other types of expensive materials
as well as being colorful and highly
decorative
they're adorned with religious symbols
they're the work of the country's best
painters sculptors and craftspeople
many customs surround the performance of
the dance
only men are allowed to take part and
they have to go through a cleansing
process before they appear
the dancers performing here are
university students
we had a lot of work to do to prepare
we weren't allowed to eat meat for three
days
and we had to wear the chat around our
necks
you have to behave very well the whole
time i'm really pleased that i was able
to take part
the main character is the god of lore
he's also known as the god of death
jag cha means the dance of the iron
palace
the palace symbolizes a state full of
demons and evil spirits
tradition dictates that the dance and
rituals are performed in a strict
sequence
some dance is akin to opera
every gesture has its own meaning
monastery back in 1786
back then a white a blue and a yellow
old man featured in the dance
over time the blue and yellow man were
forgotten and only the original white
one remains
we only came across the older figures
during research
back then our ancestors believed there
were three types of people
and they knew that we had to live in
harmony with one another
if you get the opportunity be sure to
watch this mesmerizing spectacle psalm
dance takes us into an unfamiliar
enchanted world it's a profound
spectacle that's bound to make a lasting
impression on you
a beautiful tradition indeed now europe
is one of the world's top tourist
destinations but it's not just london
and paris and rome anymore curious
travelers have started to head east now
cities like bratislava and zagreb are
seeing an influx of tourists but they
don't always have the infrastructure to
cope with the increasing volumes of
traffic in our next story we go to
bulgaria where the international airport
in the capital sofia is undergoing a
serious makeover the work on the new
state-of-the-art control tower has
already been completed an important step
forward nova tv's jiffko konstantinov
shows us more
the new tower was completed on budget in
just over a year at a total cost of
seven and a half million euros the
building was considerably cheaper than
similar projects elsewhere including a
new air traffic control tower at
britain's manchester airport
i'm proud to say that the overall
project costs were only a third of what
our colleagues in manchester spent
that's important for us and the country
as a whole
sofia airport can now cope with a
projected increase in volumes of traffic
up to seven air traffic controllers can
work in the new tower previously only
three were on duty
an elevator takes us up to the control
room where takeoffs landings and ground
movements
one of the features of the control room
are the windows positioned at an angle
and laminated to protect against direct
sunlight the controllers no longer have
problems dealing with glare
the controllers enjoy a 360 degree
uninterrupted panoramic view of the
airfield
and that means by day
or by night
the air traffic controllers can keep
track of things far better than from the
old tower
this is really just great after seven
years working in the old tower i mean
there the visibility was limited for a
number of reasons
then i came to see the new one and i was
very impressed it's so open completely
different
sofia's new control tower went into
service in december 2012.
and the new control tower is just the
start the new terminal will be able to
accommodate twice as many passengers as
the old one now it's something you might
have experienced before you're standing
in the kitchen hungry but you can't find
a thing to eat before you rush out to
get some groceries here's some food for
thought what about foraging for some
fresh and crunchy ingredients right
outside your door no not plants i'm
talking about grasshoppers or ants that
might not be your cup of tea but it's
the idea behind one mexico city's chef's
restaurant fortino rojas's pre-hispanic
or aztec cuisine is meant to take diners
back to mexico's roots quite literally
canal 21's nancy estrada takes us on a
culinary journey
if it creeps and crawls it just might
end up in my cooking pot
that's how don fortino rojas chef at the
donchon bar sums up the essence of his
pre-hispanic cuisine
i'm going to prepare a few grasshoppers
that's been a traditional dish since the
pre-hispanic times and has remained so
until the present day
hispanics
the first thing you need is a good
frying pan
then you add a little oil
chop up some garlic
and put it into the pan
hasn't had an easy life he grew up in a
very poor family he had to share the two
kilos of beans which his mother cooked
on an open fire every day with his 17
brothers and sisters
i come from puebla from a small village
called los rios to juarez
that's where i was born 68 years ago
i started to cook to survive in the big
city i only went to school for six
months
nowadays you need a high school degree
or something similar
he started experimenting with
pre-hispanic cooking in the 1960s when
he got the chance to work in the la
fonda bar as don chon used to be called
my story is
after that my life it had its shares of
ups and downs i'd worked in the docks
and as a trader
and i'd also try to earn a living as a
farm laborer
the first thing they taught me here was
to season things properly
and to prepare
i think i'll add some more chilis for
some more taste
what kind of chilis are they oh they're
hot chilis
every day fortino rojas visits the
market of san juan to buy meat he buys
ants and other insects at merced market
you can buy more or less anything
crocodile snake
wild boar
grasshoppers pheasant
quail
by reviving these very old recipes don
furtino rojas would like to put a piece
of mexican culture back on the
that's a big menu when foreigners say
that mexicans eat nothing but beans
tacos and chilis
our cuisine definitely stands up in
international comparison
competitive
the chef at donchon knows that
prehispanic cuisine gets little
attention but he thinks it's worthy of
international
junk recognition like pizzas or
hamburgers may taste good
but they're high in carbohydrates and
calories
on the donchon menu you can find
specialties like crocodile in green
pumpkin seed sauce ostrich in plum sauce
venison in pumpkin seed sauce and
pheasant on a bed of rose petals
and you can find grasshoppers like these
there's also a very diverse selection of
desserts
for dessert we have a chocolate amaranth
cake
chocolate is a typical local product
what was that
the chef admits that prehispanic cuisine
is expensive but he says it's worth it
if you really enjoy pre-hispanic cookery
you need money
you do pay a bit more for it
so
creative flavors and unusual textures
characterize this chef's popular cuisine
at the weekend mexico city's more
adventurous diners flock to his
restaurant
that's
here in mexico if people go hungry it's
because they can't be bothered
there's certainly enough good food to go
around
just delicious
for capital 21 this is nancy estrada and
javier cordero
looks delicious
don fortina rojas is not the only chef
experimenting with pre-hispanic cuisine
it's become a trend at high-end
restaurants in mexico city for all of
you intrepid diners out there good luck
now we head to bangladesh where we meet
a brave and bold group of women in the
north of the country who've been
tackling social problems in their
district whether it's alcoholism or
drugs or gambling the women of torch as
their group is called help people in
their communities get back on the right
path etv psychoadliton has the story
this is sudaminishama
unwilling to put up with drug abuse and
related crime spreading through her home
district of arampur she decided to take
a stand
she founded the muirapaibi women's group
to help fight for change in adam
sudamini started raising support for her
cause among local people
but it wasn't easy to begin with
at first people weren't very convinced
what could these people actually do but
we got organized and demonstrated
they began their campaign group back in
may 2008
there were a lot of problems
with drug addiction
with gambling and so on
drugs were being sold openly
the local community was badly affected
the whole area was being taken over by
drinkers people smoking cannabis and
gamblers
families were being badly affected
suramini sharma's women's campaign group
decided to adopt the name moira paibi
which means torch members of torch soon
started to address local problems by
speaking out against the social problems
connected with drug abuse as well as
other important issues
we are fighting against drugs
cannabis
gambling and violence against women
we campaign against underage marriage
and the custom of dowries
we're trying to increase awareness about
child labour and convince people to send
their children to school instead
and their campaign to increase awareness
of social problems and their
consequences has had an effect
they've helped many addicts kick the
habit
previously a lot of the men around here
didn't actually spend much time with
their families
fathers couldn't be bothered to help
their kids do their homework they
preferred
and it's good for our confidence and
dignity
sudamini's contribution to the community
has not gone unnoticed she was recently
honored with this award
about the women's campaign and they told
me to offer any help they required
now the situation in our district has
vastly improved and i think we're pretty
much drug
my hope is that women all over
bangladesh will start campaigning and
rid our society of drugs
and the torch is still being carried
through the streets and lanes of arampur
offering encouragement to those who want
to leave a life of drugs and crime
behind them
and finally before we go one more item
that caught our eye this week peruvian
activist richard torres wanted to take a
stand for the environment so on a sunny
sunday in buenos aires he decided to say
i do to a tree
supporters and curious onlookers
gathered in the city's rose garden to
celebrate the couple's nuptials natori
said he hoped to bring more attention to
the world's environmental problems and
it was love at first sight
well that's all for this week's edition
of world stories thanks for joining us
i'm sumisomos ganda and see you next
time
said
you